on fera avec
c'est un mauvais chiffre on sait qu'on
va devoir vraiment on va voir vraiment
beaucoup de charme ans heureusement les
amateurs du jour ne sont superstitieux
ni un patient dans leur quête les sauf
que la nature drapée de blanc leur
livrera de toute façon des moments
d'émerveillement presque en font tant
devant que s'il descend donc l'âge et
les pâtes batave aux pattes arrières
gelées l'esprit affûter les sens en
éveil les appétits s'aiguisent
nous avons fait le bonheur est dans la
progression tendue vers leur but grisés
par leur cinglant trop cinglant
peut-être le chamois déteste le vent il
ya une très bonne ouïe est un très bon
odorat par contre est une mauvaise vue
donc il se fit des cas du vent ça lui
souffle dans les oreilles et
s'inquiètent alors ils se cachent
le rendez-vous est manquée tapis sous
les épicéas les chemins sont pourtant
proches leurs traces en témoigne longue
traînée vers un pâturage improbable
consolation des promeneurs philosophes
des fautes chameau revers à tête à
unifier notre corps on a le silence et
puis l'immensité dessine c'est
magnifique
ils n'ont pas tout perdu et ne savent
pas un pouce demain si le vent s'appelle
ils reviendront